i'm actually not tired of being told
where your mask you can't say it enough
dr john lapook
thank you too new york governor andrew
cuomo faces a new threat to his job
an impeachment investigation led by
fellow democrats
it will look at claims of sexual
misconduct by governor cuomo
and allegations that his administration
withheld information on covet 19 deaths
in nursing homes
our national correspondent jericho
duncan is following this story and joins
us now to discuss
jericho the governor insists he's not
going anywhere but this is certainly a
steady drum beat of bad news for him
good morning it absolute it absolutely
is gayle
so far in total more than 120 lawmakers
are calling for the governor to resign
with 60 of them
signing a press release yesterday saying
quote
the confidence he has lost the
confidence of the public and the state
legislature earlier this week a six
woman alleged sexual misconduct by the
governor the albany times union reports
a person with direct
knowledge told the newspaper that cuomo
aggressively groped a female aide late
last year
while she was alone with him in his
private residence where she had been
called into work
the governor's acting counsel said a
lawyer for the aide
said she did not want to file a police
report
but the governor's office still had to
report the allegation to police
as required by state policy but
yesterday
the new york times reported that police
said the incident may have risen
to the level of a crime although they
had not
opened an investigation in response to
the allegation
governor cuomo said i have never done
anything like this
the details of the report are
gut-wrenching now the national
organization of women which supported
the governor in 2018
is also calling for him to resign and
really standing by the accusers and of
course the governor is under
investigation by the new york state
attorney general's office
investigators for that office launched a
new website yesterday where anyone